so we've been um we've been following
donald trump's recovery from coronavirus
it's been a very up and down erratic
period with various completely
unbelievable and deceptive claims from
donald trump's doctor
and donald trump triumphantly returning
to the white house
and then gasping for air visibly we've
been tracking it all we know donald
trump has received a variety of
different medications and we've also
observed this week donald trump has
again gone back to doing rallies this
week
and we've observed that in the evenings
at the rallies
trump seems hopped up and i mean that
colloquially he's speaking very very
quickly
uh he's more red and i think this is
even accounting for the makeup he's more
red and sort of sweaty than we typically
see
and the speculation of course is that he
is still either receiving steroids as
part of his treatment which are
kind of giving him this energy or
possibly he's being given a steroid
like to suppress a cough and to energize
him because he is still
potentially struggling with the effects
of coronavirus as we know
from the millions of cases of
coronavirus that we've now seen
sometimes you'll have this five to seven
day period and you'll be feeling better
and then later you'll be feeling worse
and it can be tough to shake it
sometimes even for months particularly
for folks in their 70s and 80s
as donald trump is well yesterday we had
a trump event earlier in the day for the
first time in a while donald trump's
events have tended to be in the evenings
earlier in the day yesterday donald
trump apparently
not juiced up and his voice was
completely failing suggesting he is
really not doing as well as he would
like us to think
and of course with coronavirus it could
go
anyway at any time in terms of a return
to more serious symptoms so take a look
at this first clip
this is from an event trump did he was
in the rose garden and he was speaking
via
teleconference to a number of different
economic
clubs the new york economic club and i
think a couple of others
and trump just really struggling here
take a look at this
simply put it's a choice between a
socialist nightmare and the american
dream
and this continued throughout the entire
event here's another one of these just
pausing struggling to speak having to
catch his breath clearing throat cough
etc
instead of corrupting horrendous trade
deals written by lobbyists and special
interests
again some of you i negotiated
pro-american trade deals
based on the principles of fairness and
reciprocity
very important i ended the nafta
nightmare
and signed the brand new u.s mexico
canada agreement into law
i've taken the toughest ever action
against china's chronic
rate abuses that we all know so well
really sounding terrible and of course
this is naturally
you know he's 74 and he had coronavirus
a week ago
causing speculation to run rampant about
is trump contagious how serious is
trump's case what are the symptoms he's
having should he really be doing these
rallies
now of course sounding like that doesn't
mean you're contagious
sounding like that doesn't even mean
it's not even necessarily because of
coronavirus people get coughs and
difficulty speaking from non-coronavirus
of viruses and conditions as well but it
does raise questions about just how well
donald trump is doing
now also during this event trump
referred it wasn't just how he sounded
the things he said also were extremely
disturbing trump referenced globalists
again
and that's another one of those words
where we wonder does trump
know that in many right-wing circles and
conspiratorial circles globalist
is code for crafty jews that these are
sort of interchangeable terms
or does trump not have any idea we don't
know but trump using the term anyway
the last administration sold out
american workers like never before
and they sold them to donors special
interests and
globalists and if you take a look we
have probably plenty of them watching
right now and
i understand where you're coming from
but didn't work out too well with me
so yeah that that is a term that um has
like america significa which sounds sort
of innocuous
but has a very ugly past that is a term
with an ugly past and unclear if donald
trump knows it of course
as far as we know other people are
writing donald trump's speeches
hard to tell sometimes whether trump is
ad-libbing or reading off of the
prompter
who knows but trump continuing to use
that term without really understanding
it
donald trump also claimed during this
event that the country if joe biden is
elected
will experience a worse depression than
1929
take a listen to this because they will
destroy this country
our country will go into a depression
the likes of which we have not
seen since 1929 and may be
so keep backing them but you know it's
wrong
and i really do believe it's only habit
that's the only reason you can be doing
it
under my continued leadership so we've
looked at this in depth
if you watch this show if you listen to
my podcast you know that the economy
does better
under democratic presidents than
republicans there is no
qualitative or quantitative case to be
made
that would support a cratering economy
if joe biden
is president and as we talked about
earlier today even the right-wing
american enterprise institute
says joe biden's tax plan would actually
be
fine for the economy and the tax hikes
would go to the richest
five percent 95 percent of the country
would get a tax decrease under joe biden
so
not based in fact donald trump
continuing to use the talking point
that he saved two million lives
by whatever it is he did on coronavirus
although if it weren't for trump he
wants you to believe 2.2 million people
would have died take a look
our aggressive and early action saved up
to 2 million lives
if you look at the original numbers it
was projected at 2.2 million
lives where at 210 000
and one is too many it should have never
happened should have never been allowed
to happen by china
thanks to advances and treatment so i i
i almost don't want to do this but i
think i should do it
this is the way that the numbers go uh
first donald trump said we had 15 cases
and they would soon be zero
donald trump then said we were going to
keep the death toll under 50
000 then under 60 000 once it got to 70
he said it would be under 100.
once it got to 100 trump said it would
be under 200 once it became clear it
would be more than 200 now donald trump
is saying listen
2.2 million people could have died so
that's the number
if literally no one does anything and
remember
even if trump did nothing as he did
nothing initially governors were still
going to do things so this
idea of 2.2 million deaths is ridiculous
but here's where the number comes from
331 million people live in the united
states
if you assume no measures whatsoever
until there is herd immunity it just
spreads
that would suggest about 70 of the
country would get the virus at that
point you would have achieved herd
immunity so
70 of 331 million is about 231 million
people
with a one percent death rate or just
below one percent death rate
if you do nothing and seventy percent of
the country gets infected
you would expect somewhere between 2.1
and 2.3 million people to die but again
that is doing nothing
that's every other country does stuff
and we do nothing no governors do
anything
no masks trump does nothing
it's a crazy comparison it's laughable
and idiotic to still be mentioning it
but because we went from zero deaths
to fifty thousand sixty seventy eighty a
hundred two hundred now 220
000 or more donald trump now has to say
well listen
we could have lost 2.2 million people uh
i don't think trump would have survived
a situation
in which the death toll was going to be
2.2 million but that's a story probably
for a different day we'll continue
discussing this
on the david pakman show instagram david
pakman show
and while you are on instagram follow me
at david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be back after this
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable as well as
all of the other gear like face shields
alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david